president Trump prepares to drop tariffs
on Mexico controversy breaks out over
the US Census and we check the mailbag
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show you finally made it it's the end of
the week I mean that's exciting stuff it
was a short week but I will tell you
here at the Daily wire it was not a
short week at all so I'm very grateful
it is a Friday but we're gonna get to
all the news and just once I can admit
it
you think cyber crime is something that
happens to other people you might think
no one wants your data or that hackers
can't grab your passwords or credit card
details you would be wrong a stealing
data from unsuspecting people on public
Wi-Fi one of the simplest cheapest ways
for hackers to make money when you leave
that internet connection unencrypted you
may as well be writing your passwords
and credit card numbers on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see which is why I've decided to take
action to prep myself from cyber
criminals I use expressvpn expressvpn
secures and anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data hiding
that public IP address expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that runs seamlessly in
the background of your computer phone
and tablet turning on expressvpn
protection that only takes one click
using expressvpn I can safely surf on
public Wi-Fi without being snooped on or
having my personal data stolen for less
than seven bucks a month you can get the
same expressvpn protection that I have
expressvpn is rated the number one VPN
service by TechRadar it comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee so go
protect your online activity today find
out how you can get three months for
free and expressvpn comm slash pen
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash been for
three months free with one year package
visit expressvpn comm slash pen to learn
more go check them out right now Express
at VPN comm /ban for that special deal
three months free with a one-year
package alrighty so fallout from Robert
Miller's big statement continues it is
obvious that the Democrats the the mood
in the room is it's time to impeach
President Trump now William Barr the
Attorney General continues to maintain
that he did nothing wrong in reaching
the finding that he reached I agree with
the Attorney General I do not think that
William bar did anything wrong in
reaching the decision that there was
insufficient evidence to prosecute
obstruction of justice nor do I think
that William bar was lying when he went
in front of Congress and said that
Robert Muller told him that it was not
true that the only reason that he didn't
prosecute Trump was because of DOJ
regulations remember this is the
the current line the current line from
Democrats and the media is that if it
were not for DOJ regulations if it were
not for the office of legal counsel
saying you can't prosecute a sitting
president and Muller would have
recommended indictment of Donald Trump
Barr says that someone Miller said
according to Barr he asked Muller
straight up is the only reason that
you're not inciting the president
because of these DOJ regulations and
Muller said no and in fact Muller has
never said that in the absence of geodes
DOJ regulations he would recommend that
the president be indicted in fact he
never reached that determination that's
the whole point he never said that and
if he wanted to say that he could have
this is exactly what William Barr was
asked on CBS this morning here's what he
had to say about Robert Miller and
whether he could have reached a decision
on obstruction of justice even with the
DOJ regulations on the books I
personally felt he could have reached
the decision in your view he could have
reached a conclusion he could have
reached a conclusion the opinion says
you cannot indict a president while he's
in office but he could have reached a
decision as to whether it was criminal
activity but he had his reasons for not
doing it which he explained and I'm not
going to you know argue about those
reasons but when he didn't make a
decision the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen Stein and I felt it was necessary
for us as the heads of the department to
reach that decision okay so this is
exactly right I mean what William Bar
says here's exactly right so he has done
his job right he said I got all the
information I made the call I took
credit for the call this is what should
have happened with regard to James Comey
who came out and made the call instead
of Loretta Lynch like Loretta Lynch
should have owned it and William Bar is
owning it good for William Bar I mean
William Bar was asked okay so what about
your legacy wouldn't your legacy have
been different if you had ruled
differently here and million bars like
listen forget about the legacy I have a
job in front of me you know this is what
this is the difference between a good
lawyer and a bad lawyer this is the
difference between a good judge and a
bad judge people who are tasked with
implementing the law their job is not to
quote unquote do justice their job is to
implement the law that is in front of
them if you want to change the law you
become a legislator you become a
politician if you are a person who is
tasked with carrying out the while you
were in the executive branch or your
task
opening law you're in the judicial
branch your job is not to quote-unquote
to justice or create a legacy for
yourself all of that is nonsense there's
a famous story about justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes very famous justice in
the early 20th century in the United
States on the Supreme Court and there's
some case that came up before the
Supreme Court and Oliver Wendell Holmes
was on the court at the time she was at
some dinner party and as he's leaving
the dinner party he gets into he gets
into a carriage to drive away and some
man runs up to him knocking on his
window and Holmes rolls down the window
the man says Mr Justice mr. Holmes do
justice sir to justice and Holmes looks
at him and says it's not my job to do
justice it's my job to interpret the law
this is correct
so William Barr is asked well why didn't
you why didn't you do the fair thing on
CBS this morning says listen that's not
my job my job is to do the legal thing
and if that means that my legacy is not
to be sung about in ODEs then I guess
that's my legacy into your career I'm at
the end of my career I've you know it's
a reputation that you've worked your
whole life right now yeah but everyone
dies and I'm not you know you know I
don't believe in the homeric idea that
you know immortality comes by you know
having ODEs on the backs you over the
centuries you know so you don't regret
taking the job no okay so good for bar
right I think the bar has done the right
thing here I think all of the talk about
how William bar is some sort of corrupt
official like Eric Holder acting as the
president's wingman I do not see the
evidence of that I think that the left
is trying to swing it that way to make
it look as though the Trump
administration would have been indicted
in the absence of William bar that if
the process had gone the way it was
supposed to go the Trump would be in
jail now and thus impeachment is on the
table what people on the left are gonna
read this the way they want to read it
and they are reading it exactly that way
so Robert DeNiro who it wouldn't matter
I mean Robert De Niro would indict a ham
sandwich if the ham sandwich had an hour
stamped on it Robert DeNiro legal expert
because he once played a lawyer on TV I
think maybe and you know when he wasn't
playing like a gangster or something
Robert DeNiro cut a PSA about the state
of the law on obstruction of justice now
I challenge Robert DeNiro to read me the
obstruction of justice statute and
explain it to me I do not think that
Robert DeNiro has ever read the
obstruction of justice statutes there's
several of them
not think that he has a law degree last
I checked I don't think he's a legal
expert in any way but here is Robert De
Niro leading former prosecutors and a
public service announcement that there
is clear evidence that president from
committed obstruction of justice and
therefore he is impeachable this is
where the heart and soul of the
Democratic Party base is not only with
impeachment but also in Hollywood Robert
De Niro the the man who gets up on stage
and bravely says to a crowd of fellow
Hollywood i'ts who hate president Trump
F Trump and gets a standing ovation his
bravery has extended to new heights with
this public service announcement
recently over a thousand former federal
prosecutors who served under both
Republican and Democratic presidents
have united to sign a statement to help
Americans understand what's actually in
the muddled report their conclusion
should trouble us all listen to them in
their own world we carefully read and
analyze the Muller report and we all
strongly believe that there is more than
enough evidence to indict President
Trump for multiple felony counts of
obstruction of justice if you or I did
what President Trump did we'd be facing
prison and no one not even the president
should be above the law in the words of
the Muller report no person is above the
law okay so Robert De Niro leading the
charge a couple of things one if the
president were not the president this
investigation never would have begun in
the first place let's be real about this
the fact is that Paul Manafort was
walking around at large until he made
the unfortunate decision of joining the
Trump campaign at which point he went
directly in the crosshairs of the FBI
and Paul Manafort was doing this crap
for years for years and the FBI knew
about it in fact he was indicted on
charges that spring from activity long
before he joined the Trump campaign the
idea that if Trump were not in a
position of power that he would be
guilty of obstruction of justice well
that's not really true and the reason
that's not really true is because he's
not been held to be indictable on
obstruction of justice charges with
regard to the people he worked with for
example his personal lawyer Michael
Cohen
so Michael Cohen has tried to provide
evidence that President Trump ordered
him to lie but even Cohen won't say
openly the Trump ordered him to lie
which means no obstruction of justice
see the difference between this and Bill
Clinton is that Bill Clinton openly
ordered people to lie to people
hey that is obstruct
of Justice Donald Trump and when I say
ordered them to light I mean officials
Donald Trump told people to lie to the
press that's bad
that is not obstruction of justice
Donald Trump told his advisers he'd like
to see Robert mullet fired and then when
they said no he didn't follow up that's
not obstruction of justice that's him
acting like a tool bag okay that's not
the same thing and it's very easy for
former federal prosecutors to sit there
and say this sort of stuff but if they
were on the job
I really doubt they would be indicted I
don't think that they think that they
could get any sort of actual actual
verdict on this on the basis of these
facts so here's where Democrats are if
you're a 2020 Democratic presidential
candidate you basically have one choice
and one choice only and that choice is
that you push impeachment and the reason
you push impeachment is because there's
no effect on you to not pushing
impeachment if you're Nancy Pelosi and
you still want to be Speaker of the
House it's gonna be very difficult for
you to retain the speakership
if you push impeachment given the fact
that there are a lot of suburban people
suburban women particularly who are not
all that interested in impeachment see
here's the truth most Americans like
stability in politics they like the idea
that they can go to sleep at night and
wake up in the morning without having to
feel the sense of crisis on their souls
it's the it's the lead reason why the
chief threat to president from
presidency is in fact President Trump
the more chaotic President Trump is the
more people feel uneasy and the more the
Democrats sort of 1920 return to
normalcy warren g harding campaign has
has legs americans want to be able to
feel that their government is basically
in safe hands that in the same way that
you go out for the night with your
spouse and you leave the kids with the
babysitter and you don't want the
babysitter to be a pyromaniac yeah it's
the same sort of feeling with regard to
government you wanna be able to go to
sleep at night take a wife out for a
night on the town and when you open up
your computer afterward you don't want
to see that the world has imploded well
the media have done a good job of
exacerbating president Trump's tendency
toward chaos but the same thing is true
on the other side with regard to
impeachment impeachment is inherently to
stabilizing most Americans aren't in
love with the idea of impeachment in
fact they think that impeachment is
likely to lead to more chaos and more
destabilization if people want to get
rid of Trump they believe there's an
election coming up in a year and a half
and we've lasted for two and a half
years and things have been pretty much
fine yes there's been a lot of chaotic
headlines but
the economy is fine no foreign crises oh
that's cool so Democrats are playing a
dangerous game but if here twenty twenty
cans in it you cannot afford not to call
for impeachment because your case is
that President Trump is a force of chaos
President Trump is a criminal so this is
the happy medium that Democrats have to
sort of push that Trump is impeachable
but we're not gonna win page we'll get
to 2020 candidates sounding off on this
in just a second first for many of us
your blinds whatever you have on your
windows
that's an afterthought but with brand
new made-to-order custom window
coverings from blinds calm you can
radically transform the look and feel of
your entire home when they're right
everything in your home looks better but
when they're wrong everything in your
home looks cheap with 15 million windows
covered over 30,000 five-star customer
reviews blinds calm is America's
number-one online retailer for
affordable quality custom window
coverings blinds.com makes the whole
experience incredibly fast and easy plus
every single order gets free samples
free shipping the free online design
consultation just send them pictures of
your house and they will send back
custom recommendations from a
professional from what will work with
your color scheme furniture in specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to make sure everything looks as good in
person as it does online and every order
gets free shipping they've really made
it easy for you so there's no excuse to
leave up those mangled blinds for a
limited time my listeners get 20 bucks
off at blinds comm when you use promo
code Ben that is blinds.com promo code
Ben for $20 off faux wood blinds
cellular shades roller shades more
blinds.com promo code Ben I've checked
them out myself I can tell you their
services are just extraordinary rules
and restrictions do apply go check them
out
blinds calm promo code Ben and get 20
bucks off everything okay blinds calm
promo code Ben pretty good stuff already
so the Democratic presidential
candidates naturally have to push the
idea that President Trump is a criminal
they will continue to push that without
actually pushing impeachment beta he's
really like I mean that skateboard has
run out of it out of juice he's really
on a pot low yeah he's having a tough
time really it's falling apart for him
but he says impeachment should be on the
table because bra if it isn't I'm
basically effed
here's beta O'Rourke talking about
impeachment in the weirdest possible way
like what I'm about to say as bait it
doesn't make any sense but I'm talking
to Chris Cuomo it doesn't have to
because Chris Cuomo doesn't understand
things so that's fine
we were attacked by a foreign power in
2016 an attack that was invited by the
the candidate who is now our president
an investigation into that TAC attack
was obstructed by this president
unfortunately the House of
Representatives today has stalled in
their pursuit of these facts in the
truth only impeachment gives them the
leverage and the mechanism necessary for
us to know exactly what has happened and
who is responsible for that
oh oh so we're still gonna go with the
collusion thing happened after 200 pages
of the collusion things didn't happen
we're still gonna go with the collusion
thing happened and the reason that we
need an impeachment hearing is that we
know what happened with Russia well that
is a different story than even Democrats
and so they're shifting back to Russia
so remember this thing started with
Trump Russia stuff and then it moved
over to obstruction of justice and now
when it looks like the obstruction of
justice thing is kind of falling apart
they're gonna move back - and the reason
we need to investigate so let's let's
get this straight
we need to investigate obstruction of
justice because there's Trump Russia
stuff and now the reason that we need to
investigate obstruction of justice on
the impeachment level is to get to the
underlying question of Trump Russia
stuff so start at Trump Russia it moves
to obstruction now it's moving back to
Trump Russia I feel like you might be
shifting the goal posts a little bit
here people get a little dizzy meanwhile
Elizabeth Warren whose basic campaign is
I will be the craziest person in the
field I mean no matter what I will be
the craziest person in the field I'll be
crazier than Bernie I will give you free
everything everything free for you now
Elizabeth Warren is pitching the vision
of president trumping frog-marched out
of the White House in Chains here she is
Elizabeth Warren did everything he could
to derail stop halt obstruct that
investigation that is a violation of the
law yeah if he were anyone other than
President of the United States he would
be in handcuffs and Ian died it okay so
no that is that is not true again that
is not true no prosecutor worth their
salt would indict a case like this there
just is not enough evidence you need to
have corrupt intent that is a very very
high bar it's not clear in the absence
of an underlying crime that corrupt
intent is present it meanwhile
there the pitch has been put out there
that President Trump is unique that he's
being uniquely protected now this is
very rich stuff coming from members of
the Obama administration so Valerie
Jarrett who is the sort of right-hand
woman to Barack Obama in the White House
she appeared on some serious XM show
yesterday and she said you know brocco
by more than been impeached in a
nanosecond if he acted like Trump mm-hmm
if President Obama had done half of the
things and said half of the things that
President Trump is saying even you know
as recently as this morning would he
have been impeached and how long do you
think it would have taken about a
nanosecond standards have slipped
dramatically and there's no earthly way
President Obama could have gotten away
with any of this not just like the the
words and the content but just the
policy reversals and what we're doing to
the fabric of our country
oh okay so yeah that okay why I guess
it's not true Barack Obama his
administration was rife with scandal
people covered up those scandals from
beginning to end
Barack Obama asserted executive
privilege to protect his own Attorney
General in the same way that Donald
Trump just asserted executive privilege
over documents supposedly to protect
William bar except Trump had much more
excuse given the fact that so much
material has already been spilled in
front of Congress it's just it's just
sheer nonsense impeachment against Obama
was never pursued because it wouldn't
have been concluded successfully and
because the grounds were not strong
enough the same thing is true for Donald
Trump meanwhile new information emerging
about disgraced FBI agent Peter struck
who led the Trump Russia investigation
as well as the Hillary investigation Fox
News is now reporting that struck who
was later removed from special counsel
Robert Miller's investigative team for
sending anti Trump text was a central
coordinator for the FBI on the defensive
briefing which included multiple
agencies three weeks earlier struck had
opened an FBI counterintelligence
investigation into campaign aide George
papadopolis a source familiar with
sensitive records documenting the August
briefing told Fox News that struck was
in a unique and apparently conflicted
position struck opened the FBI
investigation into Russian outreach to
Trump campaign aides while at the same
time he was supposed to be warning the
campaign about Russian activities so one
of the questions that Trump has always
asked about this entire investigation is
why didn't you guys just tell me that
this was going on if you suspected that
my campaign aides were acting in
nefarious fashion then why in the world
would you not actually just tell me
about it so I could fire them and folks
in the FBI are like oh it's cuz we
suspected you but the people who were
not informing Trump were people like
Peter struck Peter strux job was to
inform Trump what was going on and give
intelligence briefings to Trump Peter
struck at the exact same time that he
was refusing to turn over this
information to Donald Trump whose
campaign this was at the exact same time
Peter struck was texting with his
paramour at Lisa Paige about their
insurance policy against a men candidate
Donald Trump is Ryan Saavedra writes
over at Daily wire struck texted FBI
lawyer Lisa Paige quote I want to
believe the path you threw out for
consideration in Andy's office that B
Andrew McCabe's office that there's no
way he gets elected but I'm afraid we
can't take that risk it's like an
insurance policy in the unlikely event
you die before you're 40 as I wrote at
the time that looks an awful lot like
motivation for launching an
investigation into Trump in order to
sink Trump as a hedge against Trump's
victory the FBI's investigation into
Russian governmental interference in the
election began in July 2016 just weeks
before Struck's text message and that
means there's now more of a smoking gun
of FBI corruption against Trump than
there is of Trump colluding with Russia
her also notes that karat Catherine
Herridge of Fox News she also notes that
just a couple of days before the
infamous insurance policy text message
the two anti Trump agents had the
following text message exchange page
Trump's not ever going to become
president right right struck no no he
won't will stop it and as I wrote at the
time this is an explicit admission that
high-ranking actors in the FBI saw
preventing Trump's presidency as
paramount barring some highly damning
information demonstrating the full
legitimacy of the Russia investigation
this text from struck to page could and
should completely destroy whatever faith
that America still had in the legitimacy
of the Russia investigation John
Radcliffe Republican of Texas member the
House Judiciary Committee told Fox News
quote there was a defensive briefing of
candidate Trump on August 17th of 2016
and I can tell you what he wasn't told
he wasn't warned about Russia
investigation that Peter struck had
opened
days earlier whywould struck who had
participate at Jim Comey's direction in
a defensive briefing designed to protect
and warn a candidate be the same person
who is in fact at that time already
investigating the candidates campaign
that shouldn't happen and there should
be answers to those questions president
Trump's questions about the Trump Russia
investigation I do not think are
illegitimate and people treating them as
illegitimate have a bit of an ax to
grind we'll get the answers but I'd like
the answers and I think that Trump is
entitled to the answers I think the
American people are in fact entitled to
the answers my going theory is that this
investigation was launched in good faith
and then it quickly morphed into an
exercise in confirmation bias from
people who despised President Trump and
already saw him as a Russian tool that's
my going theory I mean the more cynical
theories that the thing wasn't even
launched in good faith and that theory
has been put out by people including
Andrew McCabe over at National Review
that basically the Obama administration
saw Trump as a threat and therefore they
authorized the FBI to go after him I
haven't seen the evidence of any of that
at this point but I think it's pretty
obvious that there was some serious
corruption going on inside the FBI with
regards to how they decided to conduct
the investigation it meanwhile the other
big story of the day is that President
Trump says that the United States will
impose five percent tariffs on all
Mexican imports beginning June 10th in a
dramatic escalation of the border clash
between the United States and Mexico is
according to the Washington Post
President Trump on Thursday said he
would impose a five percent tariff on
all goods entering from Mexico unless it
stopped the flow of illegal immigration
to the United States a dramatic
escalation of his border threats that
could have sweeping implications for
both economies now I gotta say I do not
understand this move by the president I
don't think the president should ever
have had this sort of tariffs on oh who
believes in the checks and balances of
the Constitution it is not the job of
the president who set tariffs it is the
job of the legislature to set tariffs if
Congress wants to take back that power
they absolutely should
and if Democrats moves you take back
tariff power then Republicans should
move with them to do so this is a
constitutional issue it's not even a
Trump issue the president should not
have unilateral trade Authority Congress
has the power to take back all of this
Authority if you're gonna sign some sort
of trade treaty then the Senate is
supposed to ratify that treaty
and if you're gonna set tariffs that
should be happening at the Congressional
level not unilaterally at the
presidential level the emergency
executive order it's nonsense
I don't like it from Obama I don't like
it from Trump I don't like it in either
direction by the way the president
unilaterally lowering tariffs is a
violation of the constitutional order
the Constitution prescribes that the
legislature of the United States is
supposed to be responsible for the
policy decisions the president of the
United States is responsible for
implementing those policy decisions and
working with Congress to come up with
things that can pass both the
legislative and the executive veto this
has been completely skewed over the
history of the Constitution into the
president can do whatever he wants I
don't like it I'll talk more about it in
one second first let's talk about
something we can all agree on saving
money the reality is if you're not
shopping around you're probably not
saving money so what if there was a way
for somebody to do the shopping around
for you that's exactly what honey does
honey is a free tool that you download
to your computer's browser while you
shop online honey scans the internet for
coupon codes and other discounts then it
automatically applies the coupon with
the biggest savings to your cart at
checkout like magic it takes zero effort
to install just two clicks and you're
ready to start saving anytime you shop
online
there's really no reason not to use
honey I just leave it running on my
computer all the time it's free to use
easy to install on your computer and
just two clicks don't take it from me
take it from our listeners get honey for
free at join honey calm slash pen that's
join honey calm slash pen honey is the
smart shopping assistant that saves you
time and money every time I shop on
Amazon every time I shop at mlb.com for
my baseball gear anytime I shop online
to buy my wife jewelry I promise you
honey is great it saves you money with
virtually every purchase go to join
honey calm slash Ben go check them out
right now you really have nothing to
lose it's free and you're gonna save
money join honey calm slash Ben okay so
as I say president Trump says he's now
going to impose tariffs on all goods
entering from Mexico the problem is that
he's basically taxing the American
people a tariff is attacks on Americans
now you can say that the tax on
Americans is designed to elicit changes
in policy from another country so this
has been the case that's been made to me
by folks including Newt Gingrich with
regards to president Trump's tariff
fight with China saying the only way to
get China to stop cheating is for us to
tariffs China and it'll hurt them more
than it hurts us yes it will hurt
American taxpayers but that will be
temporary because we will force the
Chinese to stop cheating
that at least is arguable and I think
there's something to it in the sense
that China is an actual geopolitical
rival to the United States attempting to
maximize its power so if they are
getting richer and we are getting richer
but they are getting richer at a faster
rate then we are getting richer that may
not in fact be good for us I think
there's an open argument historically
speaking as to whether Richard Nixon
should have opened China in the first
place
there were complicating factors at the
time like the fact that we were trying
to separate off the Chinese from the
Soviet Union but there's a case to be
made that the attempted thought
experiment that if we just allowed the
economy of China to liberalize that the
pollute the the politics of China would
liberalize that that thought experiment
has basically failed and that was a
mistake that's why I think that putting
tariffs on China not quite the same
thing as what Trump is doing here with
tariffs on Mexico what exactly does he
hope to accomplish by slapping tariffs
on Mexican goods other than the
president kind of like tariffs Mike's
tariffs well he says he wants to stop
illegal immigration that way that this
policy is not designed to elicit the
proper response it is not so you slap
tariffs on Mexican goods you're going to
accomplish a couple of things one you're
gonna tax American citizens because the
fact is that China that Mexico is our
third largest trading partner I believe
that it goes China EU Mexico hey that's
not great for Americans and these these
tariffs are gonna escalate it's gonna
start at 5% it's gonna go all the way up
to 25% so get ready for your products to
get more expensive so not good for the
economy in a near election year for the
President and for you right I mean you
are the taxpayer number two it's going
to impoverish the economy of Mexico now
what Trump would say is right that's the
threat if I impoverished the economy of
Mexico the Mexican government is thereby
incentivized to stop illegal immigration
but there's one there are two problems
with that one if the economy in Mexico
is worse where do you think those people
are going to go where do you think the
Mexicans who are living a bad economy
are going to move do you think they're
not going to move north through our
porous border in fact every period in
American history where the American
economy is doing really well and the
Mexican economy is not doing really well
you know what's a thing that happens a
lot illegal immigration also do you
really think the Mexican government
which is politically accountable
remember that the Mexican government is
going to crack down on illegal
immigration in the midst of a bad
economy
do you really think it's gonna happen
because that's still unelected that's
still an elected government how popular
do you think that government would be do
you think that government would be real
popular if they were like you know what
we're shutting down in legal immigration
so that people can't travel across the
US border and then ship the money back
to Mexico which is very often what
happens we're doing it at the behest of
Donald Trump yeah I'm sure that that
government will be long for this earth
so none of this is actually geared
toward toward success you know it
would've been geared towards success
would be a border wall that'd be really
great and a border wall would have been
much more geared toward stopping illegal
immigration without wrecking the economy
to the south of us and taxing American
citizens to do it this is this is not
smart policy the White House plans to
begin levying the import penalties on
June 10th and ratchet the penalties
higher if the migrant flow isn't halted
here's the other problem there's no
actual measure of what a halt in migrant
flow looks like also how in the hell are
you going to determine if the migrant
flow has halted in like six weeks
because the first deadline on this thing
is July 1st that's the first deadline on
this thing after the five percent
tariffs are imposed on June 10th the
White House said it would increase the
penalties to 10% on July 1st and then an
additional five percent on the first day
of each month for three months so let me
get this straight you are now giving the
Mexican government approximately five
minutes to stop the illegal immigration
flow and you haven't actually measured
what that looks like so let's say that
it's just lessons let's say it slows a
little bit is that enough to relieve the
tariffs or does it have to stop
ultimately and if it doesn't stop
ultimately you're just gonna keep
ratcheting forever we're gonna also
worth noting you know president Trump is
not a fan of NAFTA so he promptly
proceeded to rewrite NAFTA and basically
pass most of NAFTA with a few
improvements in the us-mexico trade deal
that trade deal was basically gonna fall
apart now so one of these signal
accomplishments of his trade policy
us-mexico trade is basically gonna fall
apart now for a policy that is not going
to accomplish what he seeks to
accomplish the economic consequences of
Trump's new plan could be swift in
severe tariffs are paid by companies
that import products so US firms would
pay the import penalties and then likely
pass some costs along to consumers
Mexico exported three hundred and forty
six point five billion dollars in goods
to the United States last year from
vehicles to fruits and
doubles many Mac manufactured items
crossed the border several times as they
are being assembled
White House officials didn't immediately
explain how driving up the cost of
Mexican goods would stem the flow of
migrants Mexico vowed a response that
could pitch the Trump administration
into a full-scale trade war mexico's
deputy foreign minister from North
America for North America hey-zeus shade
shad said the threatened tariffs would
be disastrous and added that Mexico
would respond too strongly in a letter
sent Thursday evening
Mexican president Andres Manuel Lopez
Obrador addressed Trump in harsh terms a
market change from the diplomatic
posture he has tried to adopt he said
President Trump social problems can't be
resolved through taxes or coercive
measures he also unloaded on Trump for
his administration's immigration policy
as I say illegal immigration is very
popular in Mexico do you really think
that killing their economy is also going
to lead the government to suddenly do
what Trump wants them to do
that seems not like a particularly smart
policy you want to keep people in Mexico
you have to make the economy of Mexico
better and you have to build a wall
those are the two things okay and Trump
hasn't built the wall for all the talk
about it and also the economy of Mexico
is only gonna get better if we are
trading with them which by the way is
also good for American citizens okay in
just a second we're gonna get two more
on this we're also going to get to a
u.s. census controversy that I think is
being overblown I'll explain in just a
second first no one really has time to
go to the post office you're busy who's
got time for all that traffic parking
lugging all your mail and packages last
time I went to the post office
I got a $100 parking ticket I didn't
need it it's a real hassle
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses stamps.com eliminates
trips to the post office and saves you
money with discounts you can't get even
at the post office
Sam SATCOM brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is that
simple with stamps calm you get five
cents off every first class stamp and up
to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters
stamps comm is a no-brainer it saves you
time and it saves you money it is no
wonder that over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps comm right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that is stamps comm enter
Shapiro for that special deal stamps
icon is great there's a reason I
personally use it and we use it here at
daily wire comm go check them out right
now at stamps calm and use promo code
Shapiro for special deals alrighty we're
gonna get to this controversy over the
census we are also going to be getting
to controversy over martin luther king
jr. but first you're gonna have to go
subscribe it is a glorious time of the
week let me point out when I give a
shout out to a Daily wire subscriber
today it is Morgan Lynnette whose post
of one posted one of lights' great and
eternal truths on Instagram in the
picture Morgan who is wearing a charming
pink dress with the blue elephant print
rights left his tears go with every
ensemble punctuated with a kissy face
emoji Morgan this is a hundred percent
true and we are 100% thankful for your
support if you wish to have a chance of
being featured on the show
becoming daily wear annual subscriber if
you're not already one and post a photo
of your tumblr on Twitter or Instagram
you can even be in the photo if you
would like to become a subscriber go to
daily wire comm click on the subscribe
button at the top of the page $9.99 a
month gets you a subscription but you
only get the tumbler with a $99 a year
annual subscription let me remind you
that your subscriptions help keep us
bringing you the show because the fact
is that we have people on our ass all
the time trying to destroy our business
and your subscriptions ensure that
honest dialogue can continue to take
place so we really do appreciate that
also check us out at YouTube or iTunes
by the way when you subscribe you're
gonna get this week's Sunday special I
think it's a really important Sunday
special it is our June 6th D Day Sunday
special in which I interviewed a bunch
of veterans from the World War two
I think it's really inspiring and
astonishing a great reminder of what
this country stands for and the great
sacrifices made so that we can exercise
our rights to free speech go check that
out you get it on Saturday when you're a
subscriber and you get all the extra
content behind the paywall and all the
rest of that stuff check us out at
YouTube or iTunes please subscribe and
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we're the we are the largest fastest
growing conservative pod
and radio show in America
[Music]
you
okay so there's a controversy that's
been breaking out one of the one of the
great lies I think that the Democratic
Party continues to tell is that the
Trump administration and Republicans in
general are vicious racists who are
seeking to water down the votes of
minorities because they don't like
minorities this is untrue what is
happening and has always happened is
that gerrymandering is designed to
benefit your political party and that
means drawing lines around your
political opponents and watering down
their districts or consolidating their
districts so there are more competitive
districts for you this happens in every
Democratic state it happens in every
Republican state the reason this has
become a national issue now is because
the Trump administration is considering
asking a citizen citizenship question on
the US census now this seems like a
no-brainer right it seems like we should
know how many illegal immigrants live in
the United States and it seems like we
should really know that for purposes of
apportionment because one of the weirder
things about the American political
system is that we have to decide exactly
how seats are apportioned in the United
States Congress remember every district
we have a one-man one-vote rule when it
comes to the House of Representatives
but the way that that works is that we
measure the population of a district and
each district has to be equivalent in
terms of population so what that means
is that a district in Montana may cover
the entire state of Montana and a
district in California may cover a slice
of Los Angeles and how you draw those
districts matters an awful lot but in
terms of citizenship we measure the
population of the district we do not
measure the number of registered voters
in the district so in other words if you
have a hundred thousand illegal
immigrants living in a district and one
registered voter living in that district
that district that one voter will have
as many representatives as another
district with a hundred thousand and one
a hundred thousand and one registered
voters right you could have a district
where it's only registered voters and a
district that is one registered voter
and a hundred thousand illegal
immigrants and they will have the same
number of Representatives that's how a
portion MIT works
so the Trump administration has been
moving toward the idea that
apportionment should not be taking place
on the basis of people who legally
should not be in the country which makes
perfect sense to me but now the the left
is trying to make the argument that to
even ask the citizenship question itself
is
of course in an argument over at the
Washington Post a long article at the
Washington Post
despite Trump administration denials new
evidence suggests census citizens
citizens citizenship question was
crafted to benefit white Republicans and
here's the way that they tell the story
just weeks before the Supreme Court is
expected to rule on whether the Trump
administration can add a citizenship
question to the 2020 census new evidence
emerged Thursday suggesting the question
was crafted specifically to give an
electoral advantage to Republicans and
white now again if inherently you
denigrate the populations of a district
because it is largely illegal immigrant
Hispanics that is going to benefit other
populations in the country including
Republicans and whites but not limited
to those groups obviously the evidence
was found in the files of prominent
Republican redistricting strategist
Thomas who feller after his death in
August it reveals that Othello played a
significant role in orchestrating the
addition of the citizenship question to
the 2020 decennial census in order to
create a structural electoral advantage
for in his own words Republicans and
non-hispanic whites plaintiffs lawyers
challenging the question wrote in a
letter Thursday morning to US District
Judge Jesse Furman the lawyers also
argued that Trump administration
officials purposely obscured Howe
fellers role in court proceedings the
letter drew on new information
discovered on hard drives belonging to a
fella which fell into the hands of his
estranged daughter who then promptly
shared them with common cause which is a
very left group the files showed that
her feller concluded in 98 2015 study
that adding a citizenship question to
the 2020 census would clearly be a
disadvantage to the Democrats and
benefit white Republicans in
redistricting again that is just
statistically true that does not
necessarily mean that it is
statistically racist in the same way
that if you read istrict and you
basically take a district that was
heavily Democrat and heavily black and
you split it into two districts where
now black Democrats have a 51% majority
in those two districts now black
Democrats have two seats presumably that
they get to take as opposed to one in
this particular district just
statistically speaking that's not a
racial breakdown question it's just a
repper it's a recognition that many
groups in the united states tend to vote
or a vote in terms of polarized racial
bloc's
now the media are spending this is this
is because they're trying to be racist
no this is because Republican
strategists are trying to be a
Republican yeah that does not mean they
don't want Hispanic people to vote it
does not mean they don't want black
people to vote it does not mean they
don't want Democrats to vote it means
they want to redistricting help
Republicans just as Democrats have
always wanted to redistricting
emma-crats and also as a general rule it
is worthwhile noting that districts
should not represent people who do not
belong in the country I don't even know
why that's remotely controversial a
Justice Department spokesman issued a
statement disputing the report of new
evidence they said these eleventh-hour
allegations by the plaintiffs including
an accusation of dishonesty against a
senior Department of Justice official
are false they said that ho feller study
played no role in the department's
December 2017 request to reinstate a
citizenship question to the 2020
decennial census again the race race
plays a role in American politics
unfortunately it does and Barack Obama
had african-americans for Obama he went
out there during the 2016 election and
he said that he would take it as a
direct insult to his own presidency if
black voters didn't show up in droves to
vote for Hillary Clinton as a referendum
on his presidency it's it's very funny
how high and mighty the same people who
purport to believe in intersectional
politics and race-based politics get
uptight when people point out that
Democrats think that way and therefore
redistricting should take into account
political factors I mean it's it's it's
pretty amazing now again I would prefer
that redistricting didn't take into
account race at all and the Supreme
Court says that it should not I agree
with the Supreme Court obviously but as
a result of redistricting will people be
split up differently yes they will and
that will benefit certain groups at the
expense of other groups because every
line you draw benefits certain groups at
the expense of other groups
unfortunately so then the media I think
are covering this in a slightly unfair
way at the very least at the very least
we'll see how the Supreme Court rules on
it it's definitely an interesting issue
so we'll keep an eye on that meanwhile
there's a story that got very little
attention this week even though it is a
bombshell
and according to the Atlanta
journal-constitution Martin Luther King
jr. allegedly had sexual relations with
at least 40 women from prostitutes
people within his inner circle according
to explosive new research published
Thursday by David J Garrow one of the
civil rights leaders for most
biographers the most shocking allegation
called from decades-old FBI files
details in 1964 incident in which King
reportedly looked on laughed and offered
advice to a fellow preacher who was
raping a woman in a hotel room
garol recounts other allegations from
formerly sealed FBI documents including
that King fathered a love child and
participated in an orgy with a female
gospel legend in an 8 page essay he
wrote to her standpoint a British
cultural and political magazine the
incidents emerged as part of a National
Archives data dump related to the
assassination of John F Kennedy in 2018
President Donald Trump ordered the
release of more than 19,000 Kennedy
related documents the documents included
some surveillance summaries of FBI
wiretaps of King between 1963 and 1966
in his home office in hotel rooms as
well as information from informants when
infiltrated King's circle the FBI
allegations chronicled by Garrow could
trigger an examination of the Civil
Rights heroes personal life in a second
I want to talk about why this matters
and why it doesn't so this of course has
been largely ignored by most of the
mainstream media now imagine that it
came out that Ronald Reagan had engaged
in this sort of behavior
he calls for the statues of Ronald
Reagan to come down immediately would
break out the calls have not been issued
for Martin Luther King statues to come
down and I don't think MLK statues
should come down why because this goes
to the heart of how we think about
people in the past people in the past
are fully shaded human beings a lot of
those people engage in true evils if
these allegations are true I mean this
is truly evil behavior a lot of people
engaged in truly evil behavior but also
did good things for the world the
complexities of human behavior human
beings are not all white hat or all
black hat they're not all good or all
evil human beings do good things and
they knew bad things human beings sin
and they commit great acts of courage
the reason we build statues to MLK is
not because we are enshrining his
personal love life not because we are
enshrining his treatment of women the
reason statues are built of MLK is
because MLK was instrumental in ending
state-sponsored discrimination in the
United States
in a unique way that brought Americans
together that is why we build statues
and it's the same thing with regard to
Thomas Jefferson or George Washington
the reason you build a statue to George
Washington is because he was the father
of our country because he was the most
important leading founding father father
figure in America we're not building a
statue of him because we are enshrining
his views on slavery or his own personal
behavior with regard to slavery the same
thing is true of Thomas Jefferson now
things get more dicey when you talk
about building a statue of a Confederate
General because then the question is
what are you paying tribute to are you
paying tribute to the Confederacy which
was an evil organization it's in his
promulgation of slavery are you building
a tribute to the person for their
personal courage is the statute built
because you are admiring the courage of
the man with MLK it's pretty obvious you
are not building a statue because of his
treatment of women you are building a
statue because of his role in the civil
rights movement if we are now going to
tear down statues of everybody who did a
great thing but also bad things even
though the statue really is meant to
commemorate the great thing there will
be no statues it turns out all human
beings do some really crappy stuff so
this MLK thing should be a great
reminder to folks or intent on tearing
down every monument or chipping names
off every building that simply building
monuments or putting names on buildings
is not an endorsement of every aspect of
a human beings life neither is voting
for someone by the way if you vote for
someone that does not mean that you
endorse every aspect of what they do or
who they are if you personally then go
on to endorse all the aspects of what
they do or who they are that is you
problem but simply voting for someone
even building a monument to someone
doesn't mean you endorse everything
about them so we ought to keep that in
mind because even people who made
tremendous contributions to humanity
allegedly can do some truly evil things
if these stories about MLK are true okay
time for some male bagging so let's get
to it
alrighty Joel says Shalom from Toledo
Spain cool as a conservative
I've been poised with who I've been
posed the following question given that
we have public services for safeties
such as fire and police departments why
should health care not be public I've
tried to argue that there are personal
decisions that affect the type of health
care needed but there are still some
contagions that cause externalities
beyond one's personal choices how would
you argue the difference between these
services what are the general principles
that would constitute a service service
to be public
okay so there's a basic view in
economics that there is a difference
between so-called public goods and
private goods
okay public goods are goods that are
what we call non excludable and nonrival
risk
okay so sunshine is a non-excludable
non-rival risk good meaning your
enjoyment of the good does not decrease
my enjoyment of the good and it's not
excludable I can't stop you from
enjoying the sunshine okay we tend to
view police and firefighters in that way
that police and firefighters are
non-excludable non-rival risk goods you
get to take advantage of the fire part
Department I get to take advantage of
the fire department your enjoyment of
the fire department does not decrease my
enjoyment of the fire department your
enjoyment of the of the police
department does not change my enjoyment
of the police department now it's true
that on the very extreme edges here then
it could be rival risk theoretically
right I mean you have a small Police
Department and to many citizens so that
means that my enjoyment of the police
department does in fact deprive you of
your enjoyment of the police department
but overall the idea that the police and
firefighters the building of roads that
these things are nonexcludable and
nonrival risk that you enjoy it I can't
stop you from enjoying it the same thing
holds true for the army right
nonexcludable and nonrival hrus the army
defends my town which means it defends
you too and my enjoyment of the military
does not decrease your enjoyment of the
military those who fall under the
category of public goods private goods
are both excludable and rival risk I own
my home and I can keep you out of my
home where I can exclude you and my
enjoyment of my home prevents you from
enjoyment of my home that is any typical
good is a private good so is health care
more like a a non excludable non-rival
risk good or is it more like an
excludable rival risk good and the
answer is my enjoyment of my doctor
prevents you from enjoying my doctor and
that doctor has a right to exclude you
from service the doctor does not have a
duty to serve you so it is more like a
private good health care is more like a
private good now you talk about
contagion contagion now moves into the
issue of externalities this is where
regulations are necessary so this is why
for example I'm in favor of government
mandated vaccinations because now you've
gotten or I'm in favor of the government
taking a role in preventing the out
spray the outbreak of contagion for
example but when it comes to you broke
your leg and now you want to go to the
doctor and get your leg fixed that has
nothing to do with me that is a you
problem
meaning that is it's an excludable rival
risk good you're gonna go to the doctor
you're gonna pay I'm not going to the
doctor I'm not paying it ain't my leg
okay that is not the same thing as
police or fire both of which are
designed to protect an entire community
and in fact crime in my neighborhood is
dependent on crime being stopped on my
front door a healthcare in my
neighborhood is not dependent on you not
being able to heal your broken leg is
why I changes a little bit with regard
to contagious disease Kris says what do
you think causes most big cities to lean
so heavily to the left is there ever a
world in which cities turn red or are
they just naturally inclined to be blue
no I think that that cities tend to turn
blue because the reality is that when
you live in an area that is more
dispersed you are less likely to
encroach on other people's property
other people's way of life you just
don't see other people that much when
you're in a crowded room the ground
rules need to be set and those ground
rules need to be complicated and they
need to and they need to set what the
common good is and that means there
needs to be some sort of overarching
Authority that sets how that works
zoning restrictions don't seem to apply
as much in areas of dive of widely
dispersed populations but if you and I
live next door to each other we're now
going to have to have a rule about
whether you can erect a smokestack on
your property or not when you cram
people together that requires a lot of
government in order to ensure that those
people are not harming each other just
that's the way it works more people and
in short in a small amount of space
means that there's a lot more
externalities which naturally means a
lot more government once the government
is involved in every aspect of your life
it's easier to also call them that
government to be involved in the
problems that quote unquote you want to
solve that that's the cities have
historically been much more liberal than
the country they will continue to be
which is why for conservatives they're
gonna have to find a different appeal to
people in cities and I think that the
culture wars provide that appeal frankly
the fact that the left has gotten so
over overbearing and it's attempts to
cram down those common rules even in
cities means that the backlash is coming
and the ineffectiveness of government
has always been a strong pitch for
conservatives but overwhelmingly cities
will remain liberal the question is only
whether that liberalism is 90/10
liberalism or 55/45 liberalism Stephen
says which trilogy is better the
original Star Wars or Lord of the Rings
Lord of the Rings
okay John says yeah I I think that's
such a clear-cut answer that it doesn't
even require explanation particularly
because Return of the Jedi has some very
serious flaws to it also Lord of the
Rings is deeply moving has something
spiritual to say listen I love Star Wars
too but the original Star Wars trilogy
whenever whenever the best movie of a
trilogy is the second movie it's not the
best role oh gee I think that that's
fair to say okay John says hey Ben I'm
really excited to see the Sunday special
with d-day veterans these men are truly
amazing I'm looking forward to hearing
their stories I wanted to know if you
think there's any historical aspects or
part of World War two that is
understudied misunderstood or that
people should be more aware of I've
always been very interested in military
history I'd like your thoughts on this
thank you and have a great weekend um
well I think that there are a lot of
aspects to World War two that are under
studied or misunderstood you know some
of those aspects include the origins of
World War two and Stalin's role in
helping to initiate World War two by
siding with with Hitler obviously I
think that the there they're a bunch of
military operations that are really that
are really ignored for example there was
a there was something called Dieppe the
Battle of Dieppe that is a fascinating
fascinating incident in World War two it
was before d-day and the Allies wanted
to see exactly how German defenses would
respond to an amphibious invasion and so
they actually organized a small
amphibious invasion in a place called
Dieppe and they sent a bunch of
Canadians mostly Canadian troops to
Dieppe to fight on the beaches knowing
full well that these guys were basically
gonna get slaughtered the notion that in
war people go willingly to their death
knowing that their mission is basically
only to gather information for example I
mean that's that's true heroism and it
does demonstrate the bloody sacrifice of
war I think that we wildly understudy
the Pacific War in World War two and we
study a lot the the Atlantic war we
study a lot the war in Germany and the
war in France we study the Holocaust a
lot we don't study nearly enough what
Imperial Japan was and truly how evil
Imperial Japan was I mean The Rape of
Nanking which happens before World War
two is absolutely shocking in
it's brutality from the fact that that
the Pacific War is understudied is a
reflection of certain sensibilities on
the part of historians to focus in on
Europe in a way that they are not
focusing in on what actually led to
America's involvement in World War two
which was frankly the attack on Pearl
Harbor and the idea of Japanese
imperialists to maximize power in the
Far East see Christopher says I've lived
in California all my life I'm now
thinking about moving to another state
due to the cost of living coupled with
the raising of a family a 15 month old
son as a Christian I'd love to live in a
state and community that share
traditional values but it seems even
registrate SAR becoming more and more
blue if you had to move your family out
of California where'd you move and why
thanks Chris well I have concerns that
other people don't have right I'm an
Orthodox Jew that means I have to find
an area that has Orthodox Jews in it
because I have to be within walking
distance of a synagogue there have to be
at least some cultural markets maybe
some kosher restaurants so that there
have to be Jewish day schools so that
limits sort of where I can go so the
biggest Orthodox Jewish populations in
the United States are unfortunately all
in very liberal areas it is New York
Chicago Los Angeles in order of
populations New York Los Angeles Chicago
and then Dallas I believe Dallas is a
growing community so we probably
considered Dallas Houston has a growing
Orthodox community we'd probably
consider Houston Texas has has a lot of
things going for it though that's you
know a personal concern that I have that
other people would not but listen I
think there are lots of red areas around
the country that have a really great
living and cost of living have a lot of
burgeoning jobs if I were not Orthodox
if I were not Jewish
I'd be looking to places you know
further north I'd be looking to I'd be
looking to Iowa I would be looking to
maybe South Dakota
I'd be looking to some of these places
that have booming economies and that are
smaller states and that means that the
smaller states are unlikely to go deep
blue anytime soon just because again
smaller states with more dispersed
populations are less likely to have big
cities governing them let's see test
says hey Ben tomorrow we celebrate my
dad's retirement from the US Coast Guard
after 30 years of service meant giving
him a shout outs we congratulate him on
this amazing accomplishment
I wish you'd included his name so I
could give him a direct shoutout but
definitely congratulations and thank you
for your service sir that is amazing
stuff Brody says good more a good morrow
been a question from a Canadian fan is
it true that Palestinians in Israel are
not allowed to vote nationally how are
power
ian's treated in israel overall thanks
Brody well it depends are the
Palestinians Israeli citizens so there
are many Israeli Arab citizens 1.2
million at last count and they represent
about 20% of the voting base in Israel
some more between 15 and 20 percent of
the voting base in Israel is in fact
Arab there are several Arab parties in
the Israeli Knesset some of those air
parties have openly called for the
destruction of the State of Israel let
me rush our leads one of them so the the
fact that Arabs in Israel vote is true
they're Arabs living under the rule of
the Palestinian Authority don't vote in
Israeli elections because they're not
ruled by Israelis Israel has set up
military blockades basically in order to
prevent the invasion of people who wish
to kill Israeli citizens but
Palestinians have been engaged in
self-rule in the West Bank and Gaza
Strip for a long time it's more
self-rule in the Gaza Strip than even in
the West Bank because the West Bank is
more integrated territorially with
Israel then the Gaza Strip is but the
Gaza Strip has been engaged in like why
should Palestinians living under Hamas
will let to come us in 2006 why exactly
should they be voting in Israeli
elections
why should Palestinians who live under
the Palestinian Authority I was informed
that that was that effectively that that
Palestinians should have autonomy why
should they vote in Israeli elections
any more than the Israelis should vote
in the Gaza elections Lindsey Alec says
hey Ben I was listening to a podcast I'm
walk and the subject of property and
productivity the host argued that with
no property tax there's no incentive the
land can sit there and waste if the
owner so decides but with the tax at
least something is gained and it can
also encourage the productivity in order
to pay the tax what are your thoughts on
the taxing of private property as a
means to encourage your owners to make
the land in which they own productive
love the show well I'm against property
taxes because once I pay for it the
government no longer has a role once I
pay for there's no other product in the
United States where you pay a sales tax
on it and the next thing you know you
have to keep paying a tax on it every
single year when I buy a car I don't
keep paying a tax on the car every
single year when I buy property I pay a
certain sales tax effectively speaking
and then I'm supposed to pay for the
value of the property every single year
a percentage of the value of the
property and very much against property
taxes and I do not think that it creates
an incentive to cultivate the land
presumably the reason that you paid to
cultivate to buy the land in the first
place is because you want to
cultivated also Locke was a fan of what
was called adverse possession which was
the idea that if you buy a piece of land
and you just leave it there fallow for
20 years and you never visit it and
somebody comes and establishes their own
house on your land and then proceeds to
cultivate the land that it becomes
theirs this is actually a part of
American law adverse possession I
believe there was even a case if I'm not
mistaken against like Oprah Winfrey a
while back in which somebody actually
did this it was basically squatter's
rights there wasn't squatted on some
property that you never visited debbie
says with the speech that Molitor gave
yesterday on his way out the door as
predicted it has ramped up the Democrats
called for impeachment obviously now it
looks like it could become a timing game
with the election around the corner if
the house were to impeach next year does
the Senate have to vote on it would it
be possible that the Republicans could
find themselves without a viable
candidate on election day do two
incumbents
typically not being primary how would
the Republicans safeguard against that
so they have two primary him well ass
but not least if Trump were to be
impeached in his second term and Mike
Pence became president how the office
for vice-president be filled so the the
factual question of who replaces the
vice president it's not a
constitutionally appointed office so my
understanding is that pence could
appoint the replacement VP I don't think
that there is provision for this you
know what I'm not actually sure that
question that's a really good question
that might be in the constitutional
amendment about the line of succession
I'm gonna check that out because that it
slips my mind frankly at this point so I
will I will check I don't think that
it's like the Speaker of the House then
kicks up to the vice presidency I'm
pretty sure that's not the case I think
that the office might even remain vacant
I'm not sure really good question with
the speech that Muller gave yesterday
let's see if the house were to impeach
does the Senate have to vote on it no
the Senate is not after vote on it
theoretically they could just kill it
and not do anything but they would vote
on it and they'd vote to end it the
Republicans will not find themselves as
a viable candidate on election day that
that's not a thing Michael says Ben
Muller made it clear that he had no
ability to incite the President did he
have the ability to officially recommend
impeachment well he has the ability to
recommend indictment in the absence of
the DOJ rules which is an effective
recommendation of impeachment that's
what Barra said today I think that is
correct there is nothing in the DOJ
rules that says in the in the absence of
this rule we would we would vote to
indict right or we pushed
night he could have said that that would
have led to impeachment there's nothing
that officially says he can't say that
Trump should be impeached she could have
gotten up there at his statement and
said that that because again impeachment
is a political matter not a criminal one
what's weird about what Muller did is
that he was appointed to investigate
criminal matters and then he didn't rule
on the criminal matter instead he
basically quasi said impeach Kevin says
hey Ben if you had to guess what do you
think it's like in the Oval Office when
Trump and Pelosi have meetings do you
think the artists mean to each other
face to face as they are publicly I
laugh out loud thinking about the
awkwardness in that room loved the show
thanks for your crazy dedication to
bringing us the truth well Kevin I
appreciate it um no I think they
probably get along until the cameras go
on and they're mean to each other
because I know many Democrats in
Congress I know many Republicans in
Congress and that's basically the way
this works if people understood how
chummy everybody is behind the scenes
I'm not sure whether they would be
happier or more angry but the fact is
that a lot of this is for public show um
you know from yeah President Trump and
Nancy Pelosi were getting along up until
the point where she basically called him
crazy and said he should be thrown out
of office so and remember Trump was
getting along with Dianne Feinstein so
much at a gun control meeting that
Republicans had to reinforce and Trump's
you stick with his principles as opposed
to getting chummy with people in front
of him all right time for a quick thing
that I like and then we will do a thing
that I hate so because I have a young
children this means that I get to watch
kids movies which is fun one of the kids
movies that I watched the other day with
my daughter she is obsessed with How to
Train Your Dragon she loves it
and she had not seen How to Train Your
Dragon 2 or 3 I still will not show her
to because she's a little bit too young
to understand like parental Beth I think
that would upset her too much he'd have
nightmares but how to train your dragon
3 is a really nice cute innocent movie
it's worth to watch it's good for kids a
little too scary for kids who are maybe
under 5 or 6 but beyond that definitely
doable here's a little bit of How to
Train Your Dragon 3 the hidden world
there were dragons when I was a boy
where they went only a few know our
story changed the world forever it's
pretty it's pretty fun it's a cake and
it's got some really great scenes it's
got humour also the music is great John
Powell who did the music for How to
Train Your Dragon incredibly talented
dude I also did the music for Bourne
Identity among other films so go check
it out it's good for kids by the way I
did look up well that trailer was
playing who replaces the VP if the VP
becomes president and my original answer
was correct he does select his own VP at
that point okay other things that I like
so this was just hilarious
Charlamagne tha God has a show called
The Breakfast Club when he had on
senator Elizabeth Warren and things did
not go great for Elizabeth Warren he
started asking her about why she claimed
that she was Native American for years
and it was awkward your family told you
you were Native American yeah
Charlemagne tells me I'm Dominican but I
don't believe you are how long did you
all along it I could there was some
report that said you were Native
American on your Texas bar license and
that she said you had Native American or
some documents when you were a professor
at Harvard like why'd you do that so
it's what I believed were they any
benefits today no Boston Globe did a
full investigation it never affected
nothing about my family ever affected
any job I ever got um didn't get a
discount in college now it's kind of
like the original rates with those are a
little bit we're all white woman
pretending to be black this is what I
learned from my family don't
ouch ouch yeah that's gonna sting a
little bit Wow okay time for a quick
thing that I hate
okay so the quick thing that I hate
turns out North Korea's super evil and
by North Korea I mean the dictatorship
of North Korea so remember at that time
that President Trump says that he trusts
Kim jong-un and that Kim jong-un is a
really strong young leader yeah here's
what happened in the aftermath of some
negotiations that went wrong according
to USA Today North Korea executed its
special nuclear envoy to the United
States as part of a purge of senior
officials over the failed summit between
Kim jong-un and President Donald Trump
according to South Korea's Chosun Ilbo
newspaper Kim Hyung was executed by
firing squad in March along with four
other foreign ministry officials the
paper reported North Korea neither
confirmed nor denied the report South
Korea's government was not able to
confirm the claim they reported that Kim
kyung-ho and other senior officials were
shot after being accused of spying for
the United States the paper reported
that Kim jong-un ordered the purge amid
mounting dissatisfaction with the summit
in Hanoi the second time Kim and Trump
met face to face for talks in Vietnam
that failed to reach a deal because of
conflicts over the White House's calls
for complete denuclearization since then
I made a diplomatic standoff North Korea
has resumed short-range ballistic
missile testing Trump has tweeted out
North Korea fired off some small weapons
which disturb some of my people and
others but not me okay this suggests
that maybe we shouldn't be treating Kim
jong-un as either an authority on
President Joe Biden Joe Biden's
intelligence or on international affairs
generally or trusting him probably you
shouldn't trust the guy who the
negotiations went bad and he just shot
everyone that seems kind of like a
problem just gonna put that out there
all right we'll be back here at later
today with two additional hours of ben
shapiro show otherwise we'll see you
here on monday have a wonderful relaxing
weekend stay off Twitter folks just stay
off of it we'll see you here on Monday
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
betting market selection models and a
political scientist who has correctly
predicted nine presidential elections
all say Trump is headed for victory in
2020 we will examine why then Liz Warren
gets wrecked on the radio the world's
tiniest baby ever is born Elton John
hates his country and conservatives open
up a major fight over the definition of
conservatism check it out at the Michael
Noel's show